réseau avec les petits malins de
l'internet pour posséder un site et une
adresse sur les autoroutes de
l'information comment vit il suffit
presque de donner son nom les plus futés
s'y installe en utilisant le patronyme
de grandes firmes
quand celles ci veulent à leur tour y
accéder elles sont obligées ou de faire
des procès ou de racheter leurs
enseignes
une conférence ait lieu cette semaine à
washington pour moraliser comme c'est
déjà le cas en france l'accès au net
romuald renault bruno livertout internet
comme une gigantesque toile d'araignée
informatique qui permet via un
ordinateur de communiquer d'échanger des
données des sons et des images en
quelques secondes
n'importe où dans le monde des
informations disponibles sur des sites
internet souvent créés par des
entreprises ou marques comme par exemple
ici celui de france 2 pour chaque site
une seule adresse qui correspond
généralement au nom de la société
seulement voilà n'importe qui sur le
globe
à condition d'être le premier peut
acquérir un ou plusieurs sites et donner
à chacun le nom d'une marque connue sans
pour autant en être le propriétaire du
coup lorsque la véritable marque veut
créer son site
la place est déjà prise plusieurs
milliers d'entreprises comme par exemple
mcdonald's se sont fait doubler pour ces
sociétés
prise de vitesse de solutions le procès
long et coûteux ou surtout le rachat
négocier il semblerait que pour certains
oui ça et être effectué sur l'année
peut-être un pour cent de ceux qui ont
joué à ce jeu là on en retirait
réellement les marrons du feu puisque
quand vous déposez un nom de domaine
vous avez quand même un coût donc c'est
un pari derrière vous allez trouver
quelqu'un qui va vous l'achetez et en
plus à bon prix et suffisamment pour
pouvoir couvrir tout ce que vous avez
déposé en espérant les revendre et vous
allez par an la france joue l'exception
un organisme le à nice et france est le
seul habilité pour l'attribution des
noms des sites nationaux sur l'internet
50 nouveaux sites sont installées chaque
jour les impossible de se saisir d'une
marque déposée
comme c'est le cas au japon aux états
unis c'est le far west au sens où la
règle qui est appliquée c'est le premier
arrivé premier servi
en france la plus con pas cette règle
nous avons un plein de nos marges qui
s'appuie sur des réglementations
en vigueur et sur les documents à
fournir depuis quelques mois les
transactions financières se multiplient
entre sociétés multinationales et
internautes peu scrupuleux
aux etats unis la revente de sites aux
noms célèbres dans l'agroalimentaire et
la pharmacie se serait négocié jusqu à
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
francs